call of duty dropped a ton of
information about cold war season 3
and what's going on next with warzone
buckle up because we've got a lot to
talk about
it looks like the events of war zone are
coming to a head and the end is near
after more than a month the zombies have
finally managed to fully infect verdansk
so on april 21st we finally get to see
what the end of verdance will look like
as we know it
moving on to cold war the face of season
three is wraith
she's working alongside stitch
throughout season three's story
beginning with her first mission in the
yamantau mountains but she's not alone
knight also joins the fray later this
season he's another member of perseus
working with wraith
and his bio reads that he's happiest
when killing in close quarters
later in season three we will also meet
antonoff he's a warsaw pack member
who's got a rough pass in bomb defusal
work tons of jail time and is now a
hired gun
last but not least captain price comes
to cold war personally i thought they'd
go with calling him lieutenant price to
make things easier
but no instead we will have a separate
price for cold war and modern warfare
and both will be represented in warzone
separately moving on to some new weapons
we've got a total of six coming to cold
war including the swiss case sniper
rifle
the ballistic knife baseball bat melee
weapon the carve 2
tactical burst rifle and some returning
classic submachine guns
including the ppsh and the amp63
which you might remember as the pm from
black ops 1.
also added to the score streaks is the
strafe run
you'll be able to use these weapons and
gear in some all new locations coming to
multiplayer
these maps include duga for multi-team
modes yamantau a snowy base deep in the
yementau mountains
diesel a smaller map set in a new
mexican gas station
and last but not least standoff a
classic map from black ops 2 will return
as a 6v6 map
continuing the cold war story some more
narrative events are coming to season 3.
at the end of season 2 we saw frank
woodson company search for adler in the
jungles of laos with only a dead end to
show for it
in the limited time mode the hunt for
adler it looks like we're going to
uncover some more intel
while unlocking goodies like operator
skins charms calling cards and more
some new and returning modes are coming
back to cold war season 3.
first we have sticks and stones the
throwback game mode which faces you off
against enemy players
using only the crossbow ballistic knife
and tomahawks
later in the season we'll see multi-team
elimination a new mode for larger scale
battle
teams of four will try to survive
expanding radiation zones
with limited redeploys like warzone you
will need to scavenge for armor
weapons and score streaks the last team
standing wins and will securely
ex-film and last up we have some news
for zombies fans
zombies mode is getting some updates
beginning with a field upgrade called
toxic
growth this puts a thorny barrier in
front of the player that slows down the
undead and hurts them in the process
upgrades include exploding thorns and
double damage
for outbreak players dugo will be added
into the rotation of levels
as well as two new vehicles the fast
attack vehicle the fav
and the cargo truck in this update you
will finally be able to upgrade the die
machine wonder weapon
to get to even higher rounds in outbreak
and finally for onslaught mode
yementau and standoff will be added to
the rotation
we've got a ton of call of duty
information coming soon including what's
really going to happen with the warzone
event so stick around you don't want to
miss it thanks for watching
you